un vrai barnum ce chantier à tourouvre
la route high tech se construit à l'abri
sous une tente de 125 mètres de long car
la pause des 2880 panneaux solaires dans
l'épaisseur de la chaussée ne supporte
pas l'humidité excessive et les résines
remplaçant l'asphalt doivent être mises
en oeuvre dans une place de température
précise pas de retard pour autant les
1000 mètres de voies seront achevés en
moins de cinq semaines et vers la
mi-décembre la départementale 5
connectés au réseau électrique vivra ses
premiers kilowatts
bien sûr ce projet était de bien plus
grandes dimensions que ce que nous
avions conçu jusqu'à présent nous a
contraints en quelque sorte à réfléchir
plus grand en terme de préparation de ce
chantier vous voyez que c'est un
chantier de très grande ampleur
un kilomètre de voirie en revêtement
whatwg est donc en terme d'expérience ce
chantier est extrêmement important et
nous apporte beaucoup au quotidien dans
sa réalisation
cet équipement inédit pourrait suffire à
alimenter une ville de 5000 habitants
mais la route soler possèdent un
potentiel d'innovation extrêmement vaste
produisant sa propre énergie
elle sera capable d'offrir quantité de
nouveaux services aux usagers
on peut imaginer donc maintenant cette
route autonome en production d'énergie
aussi en capacité d'intégrer de la
signalisation dynamique acérée des led
pour faire de l'affichage de
signalisation routière
on peut imaginer des applications
d'induction de recharge par induction et
même une fonction anti verglas prochain
challenge pour l'entreprise faire tomber
les coûts de production 5 millions
d'euros ce premier kilomètre réalisée
dans l'orne
la mécanisation adapté aux exigences de
tels chantiers est à l'étude
objectif ne pas être plus cher à
l'investissement cas traditionnel chant
d'énergie solaire